WHAT I CAME TO BE EXTRA FEE, YO
JUST COULDN'T LET IT BE.
SIR PAUL MCCARTNEY, THE FORMER
LEAD SINGER OF A COVER BANNED I
URGING STARBUCKS TO PUT A
SURCHARGE ON PLANT -BASED MILK
OPTIONS EVEN THOUGH THE COSTS
MILK TO PRODUCE AND ARE AN
ABOMINATION BEFORE GOD.
USING A BEACON PAPER INCLUDING
--
HE FRETS I UNDERSTAND THAT NONE
OTHER COUNTRIES LIKE YOU CAN AN
YET THERE IS THE SAME CHARGE FO
BOTH TYPES OF MILK BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO POLITELY REQUEST THAT
YOU CAN SET UP THIS POLICY, ALS
WOULD STARBUCKS USA.
HOPE FOR THE FUTURE OF THE PLAN
AND ANIMAL WELFARE COPY WERE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THIS POLICY.
NOW, WHEN HE'S NOT RIPPING OFF
THE MONKEYS, MCCARTNEY HAS HAD
LONG HISTORY OF PROMOTING A
VEGAN LIFESTYLE AND HE'S A HOUS
MILK GENERATE SEE MORE
DEFINITION.
YOU CAN SAY THE SAME THING ABOU
HUMAN MILK BUT IT JUST TASTES
BETTER.
WE ARE PAYING A LOT LESS FOR
PLANT MELT, I BET I CAN THINK O
ONE GUY WHO WAS ALL FOR IT.
>> I EAT A PLANT -BASED LIFE.
I EAT A PLANT -BASED CENTERED
LIFE.
SOME PEOPLE WANT TO CALL ME
BEACON.
IEF PLANT -BASED CENTERED LIFE.
>> YOU GOING TO BE A GREAT MAYOR
.
>> I DRINK COCA-COLA.
>> BY THE WAY, THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU ARE DEALING WITH TEA.
IS HOPING A BEHIND YOU TO TAKE
YOUR TEA.
>> THIS IS THE WAY THAT --
THIS IS A PROBLEM WITH HOW
AMERICANS MAKE TEA.
AND NEVER GET IT RIGHT.
THAT THE MILK IN FIRST.
STEW IT FOR 4-MINUTES, NOT FIVE
NOT THREE.
WE CAN START A REVOLUTION TO
BRING THAT.
NEXT BY GO INTO BUT I THINK THA
SIGNED UP AND THEY'VE LEARNED
ABOUT VIOLENCE SOLVES ALL
PROBLEMS AND THEN SKY DIAPERS G
DIRECTLY INTO AN ACTIVE VOLCANO.
THEY DON'T SURVIVE THE BOUTIQUE
COMES OUT GREAT.
AND THEN THEY HEAT UP AT THE
FLAMETHROWER AND NACHOS.
SAY GOODBYE TO EARL GREAT AND
SAY HELLO TO EARL RED, WHITE,
AND BLUE.
IT IS AMERICAN TEA.
>> THAT WAS AMAZING.
>> THAT WHAT THE BREAK THAT
SEGMENT OF DOING TEA.
>> IS THIS THE THING THAT SIR
PAUL SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT?
>> I AM A MASSIVE BEADLES JUNKIE
.
>> IT ENDED UP COSTING HIM
60 MILLION POUNDS AND I OWE HIM
ONE.
>> SO THERE'S SOMETHING
INSUFFERABLE VOTE SELF-RIGHTEOU
VEGANS.
I THINK THE PARTICULAR THING TO
EXERCISE ME ABOUT IS THEY --
[INDISCERNIBLE]
ALMONDS INVOLVES THE
EXTERMINATION OF YOU AND SOME
BEES IN CALIFORNIA OVER 5-6 WEE
PERIOD EVERY YEAR.
IT'S THE SAME WITH VARIOUS
OTHERS.
AND THEY ARE NOT AS SQUEAKY
CLEAN.
THESE ARE THE LITTLE GUYS.
AND I WILL LET YOU STAND UP FOR
THE LITTLE GUY.
THEY NEVER CARE ABOUT THE BLOOD
BEES.
>> THEY NEVER CARE.
THEY SHOULD CARE ABOUT THEM IS.
PRINTER ALL MY MILK ON YOUR HIG
MORAL GROUND.
I LIKE MY PROPER KYLE AND PROPE
MILK.
>> LOOK AT YOUR OWN BACKYARD
FIRST AND LOOK AFTER THE BEES.
IS IN IT IRONIC THAT THE BEATLE
PREFER PLANTS.
>> IT'S ALSO IRONIC WHEN YOU
HEAR BILLIONAIRE COMPARE ABOUT
THE PRICE, AN EXTRA BUCK AT
STARBUCKS.
HE HAS A SET OF STEAK GET IT FO
HIM.
EVERYTHING ABOUT GENDER AND --
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS ALL MY
MILK ALMONDS DO NOT HAVE,
THEREFORE THEY CANNOT PRODUCE
MILK.
IT IS GROUND-UP ALMONDS AND IT
IS NOT JUST THE BEES, RATS,
LITTLE LIZARDS, ALL THE LITTLE
THINGS.
TONS AND TONS OF DIFFERENT
SPECIES OF ANIMALS THAT ARE
WIPED OUT BY THESE.
YET THEY GET MAD BECAUSE THEY
KILL A COW FOR ME.
THE PROBLEM IS I GUESS THE COW'
KEEP YOUR.
>> IT IS EASY TO POINT OUT.
>> THE ASSIGNED
SELF-CONSCIOUSNESS TO SIZE SO W
ASSUME THAT BEES DO NOT THINK.
>> OF COURSE THEY DO.
LIKE JIM ACOSTA.
>> AND HE IS BARELY CONSCIOUS.
>> AND THERE IS THAT.
>> I LIKE COUNTRY MUSIC.
>> OH, NO.
[SPEAKING AT ONCE]
>> SOME THAT THEY WERE OVERRATED
, LIKE CHANGING MUSIC
WASN'T ENOUGH FOR YOU?
IF YOUR PURSE WHEN A FAN, THAT
IS ONE THING.
>> YOU KNOW, HE MIGHT --
SHE MIGHT NOT EVER BE ON THE
SHOW.
I'M SORRY.
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY THAT
THERE IS NOTHING MORE THEN AND
CELEBRITIES SENDING AN OPEN
LETTER SAYING I NEED --
IF IT WAS LEONARD SKINNER, IT
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN THIS WAY.
I'M NOT A BEATLES FAN.
AND I DON'T LET THAT.
I'M A HUGE LEONARD SKYNYRD
BANNED.
SLOW DANCING, FREE BIRD, OFTEN
ALONE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD TO THIS
BEETLE MANIA?
>> SURE.
I'M A HUGE BEATLES FAN.
I DON'T KNOW THE GUY, PEERS.
HE DOESN'T KNOW I EXIST AND
NEVER WILL BE UP AT THAT DOESN'
STOP ME.
NEVER HAS.
BUT I KIND OF LOVE IT BECAUSE I
KIND OF PROVES HOW FALL OF
STARBUCKS IS IN A WAY BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THIS WHOLE SECTION ON
THE WEBSITE IN THEIR STORES
ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT IS LIKE THEN TAKE SOME.
THEY CAN AFFORD TO MAKE IT ALL
THE SAME PRICE, BUT IT JUST
PROVES THAT THEY ARE CAPITALIST
THAT LIE ABOUT IT.
>> THERE SHOULD BE AN TAX FOR
BEING AN ANNOYING BEACON.
>> IF YOU WORK AT BILLIONAIRE --
>> TO BE FAIR TO HIM HE MIGHT B
DOWN TO HIS LAST 800 MILLIGRAMS.
GIVE THEM SOME.
>> IT'S ALSO AN ATTACK ON WOMEN.
THESE ARE 95% FEMALE.
I'M JUST THROWING THAT OUT THERE
.
THAT'S ANOTHER ATTACK ON WOMEN.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU KNOW AS
MUCH ABOUT THE THING AS I D